When the service worker
is first registered,
it triggers an install event.
This is the perfect time to pre-cache
all of the resources needed for
the App Shell.
let's have an event listener that
will fire on the install event so
that we can cached the resources
required by the end of the App Shell.
The HTML, CSS and any JavaScript.
First, we need to open the cache with
caches.open and provide a cache name.
Providing a cache name allows us
to version files or separate data
from the App Shell so that we can easily
update but not affect other content.
Once the cache is open we can call
cache.addAll which takes a list of URL's
and then fetches them from the server
and adds the response to the cache.
Unfortunately, cache.addAll is atomic.
If any of the files fail,
the entire cache step will fail.
And I guess it would be a good idea to
provide a list of the resources that we
want to cache as part of the App Shell